hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that just happened uh in
the european online club cup
playoffs it was suggested to me on
twitter so very happy about that
it's shakira versus vasily van chuk and
we haven't had a game
uh by well not either of them we we had
a few games by mommy
but we haven't had a game uh by uh good
old chucky for
quite a while now so i'm very happy that
this game occurred uh and without
further ado let's check it out
and see uh why it's such a such a nice
game so mamadirov with uh the white
pieces
uh opens with d4 uh we have knight to f6
c for g6 going for a kings indian
defense setup
knight to f3 and bishop to g7 so
a nice king's indian defense uh we have
e3
and uh vasily immediately castles sorry
e3 and castles and also
uh sorry about the previous video i i've
seen a lot of you mentioned that there
are some weird noises in the background
i couldn't hear any but
this is already the second time that it
happened like in you know in a few
months
and i think um the reason why i can't
hear it is because i never use
headphones i'm pretty sure
maybe it's something that only headphone
users uh hear
but i couldn't figure figure out what it
was so well either way sorry about that
i have no idea how that happened like
you you guys were mentioning like there
was some sort of a video playing in the
background
uh i i checked like that there were no
videos playing in the background maybe
something was playing in the background
and then it you know uh came to a stop
and then
i couldn't figure out what it was uh
either way i
checked now i'm pretty sure there's
nothing playing in the background
so here we have castles and now bishop
to e2 mommy they are now ready to castle
also
we have b6 now vasily also wants to get
his light square bishop to this
long diagonal and here we have castles
bishop b7
and now queen to c2 yeah we have e6 and
now b4
and interestingly in 2019 in the
uh super bet uh bucharest rapid
tournament uh mamadirov already had this
position with the white pieces against
vladislav
uh and that game ended in a draw and in
that game queen to e7 was played however
here
vasily goes for d6 it's a new move so
already as of move eight we have a
completely new game
it's hard to say if vasily knew of this
game and then prepared something extra
for mama jarv or
is just a coincidence but uh you know
it's it's hard to say i i
tend to think it's not a coincidence uh
so here bishop to b2 continuing
development
and knight b to d7 yeah now preparing to
strike here with c5 we have knight to c3
and now the immediate c5 why not
uh you want to open up some files so you
have to develop the queen bring the
rooks to the open files
we have d captures on c5 d captures and
now b5 momodaro closes off the queen
side
and now he wants to bring of course his
rooks to the d file maybe even double up
if possible so knight to e4
vasily uses a trick here to trade off
some pieces and um
uh the problem is the bishop on b2 will
be undefended if you go for something
like knight captures on e4
then we're just gonna see bishop
captures and well the queen is under
attack so you'd have to capture it queen
captures and then bishop captures here
uh and the black black would be
perfectly fine black would retreat uh
with bishop to g7 and everything would
be uh perfectly fine so here
mamidarov takes this opportunity to play
a4
as uh just you know uh strengthening the
position on the queen side
and the queen to c7 now vasili also
wants to bring his rooks over to the
open d
file uh we have rook after d1 and now
rook f2 d8
we have h3 making some breeding room for
the king here
and now knight to e5 and here these
knights are now
deadly and you have to do something
about that you can just let
your opponents knights you know enjoy
themselves like the this in the center
of the board
so knight captures on e4 seems like
winning a piece but not really
uh because this tension still exists so
bishop captures attacking mama the arabs
queen queen captures and now knight
captures on f3 comes with
check so bishop captures and finally we
eliminated that
annoying bishop on b2 bishop captures on
b2
uh we have rook 8 to b1 and now you have
to be careful in positions like
these especially when you're playing the
games because this there's this
thing called automatic uh reply or
automatic capture when someone attacks
your piece or you know someone captures
your piece
you don't want to always just recapture
or you know if someone attacks your
piece don't just retreat always look for
that
uh nice tuition two that in between move
that could you know
turn the tide uh in your favor because
here if you just go back which does make
sense for example bishop to g7
uh you might run into something like
queen capture 78 just uh
grabbing two rooks for the queen and
here black is close to lost
if not lost uh there's really no control
here for black
all of these pawns are on light squares
you have a dark square bishop once
white doubles up rooks and the d file it
it's just game over there there's
really no counter play here for black so
uh you have to be careful of things like
that and of course vasily is he plays
rook captures on d1 with
check we have rook captures and now rook
to d8 trying to switch off the the
remaining rook
we have rook capture queen captures and
now queen to be
seven mamadou says your a7 point is not
defended and there is no way for you to
defend it so i'm just gonna capture it
and uh if you notice we have bishops of
opposite color so if it
if it goes to an end game it doesn't
really matter if momodaro will be up
upon
in a bishop of opposite colors uh it's
uh well
very very not very easy but it is most
often possible to hold the default hold
that game to a draw
so here with bishop to c3 uh vasily says
now okay
capture my pawn i'm gonna play some like
bishop e1 bring the queen to d to go
after your f two pawn
so that's gonna be my counter play and
we have queen captures on a7 it's
perfectly fine to capture the spawn
bishop to e1 going after the f2 pawn and
now we have bishop to c6 here
mamadourov had a chance here he could
have just played queen to a8 force a
queen trade
and that's it we go into captures
captures and yes white is up a pawn but
uh i mean you are never crossing the
dark squares here
and it doesn't matter if you're you're
up upon it's just going to be a draw
here
uh but instead after bishop to e1
mamidarov said uh okay
i'm i'm probably going to be able to
hold this to a draw whatever i play so
i'm just going to play bishop to c6 and
now
black has this very unpleasant choice of
if he moves the queen away from the back
rank then i'm already attacking f7 i'm
gonna play bishop to e8
and it's gonna be it's gonna be pretty
troublesome for
for black to play this and the queen
still has to keep an eye on this pawn
uh i also have some plans of uh well if
the bishop ever leaves this diagonal
maybe i can even sacrifice this pawn to
start pushing this pawn so there are
options here black could maybe go wrong
but maybe white has already
gone wrong and well feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the
absolute best move for vasily
well i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding a move
that's
most certainly is not easy to find and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's
no no it's not that it's king to g7 king
to g7
and now white uh has to deal with the
very unpleasant reality of things that
what is he even doing here uh because
now
now you are preparing to move your queen
and white will
not be able to do any maneuvering with
with checks along the back rank and what
what move is there for white so uh the
the problem is if black just continued
with something like
queen to d2 here going after this queen
captures you have this queen to b8
check and then you can just easily shift
to the queen over to f4 and everything
is nicely defended for example king here
even queen to e5 check and if king f8
you can still play queen f4 the f2 pawn
is defended you're still up a pawn
but here vasili played the ingenious
king the g7 and i'm sure
most of you or maybe even all of you did
uh king to g7
and now what what can white play here i
mean
uh now queen to d2 will be deadly
because the white queen cannot move with
check
and uh you could try something uh you
could try queen to d7 this was played in
the game but
there is the very tricky idea of bishop
the e8 here
mamadourov could have maybe sacrificed a
piece but
although it looks very interesting and
now queen captures an f7 is coming it's
a piece sacrifice and then you capture
here on b6 and now you have two
connected past pawns
which well usually is not only
compensation usually that's you know
a means of achieving victory however
here not so much because after queen to
e7 defending the spawn
uh there's really no good way for you to
uh do anything because if a5 you try to
push this pawn to victory
queen of oops queen to f6 now
going after f2 and there's no way of
defending uh whatever you play is just
game over if you play f3
then you get this bishop g3 guarding
these two squares and queen to a1 will
be checkmate and if you try to run away
with the king
i just queen to b2 and now again you are
faced with a very
very difficult choice of getting
checkmated on this square or getting
checkmated on this square so it doesn't
really it doesn't really matter
uh so here uh it doesn't work like maybe
you could play it but
uh i mean uh the simple idea of maybe
just trying to push pawns will not work
and
black will always be better however here
queen to d7 was played it makes sense of
course you want to trade the queens but
now
now vasily just plays queen to h4 and
now the f2 pawn is under attack and
there is no way to defend it that's the
problem
uh if you go for something like f3 which
you can
then comes bishop to f2 check then this
pawn falls then all of a sudden you're
you're just uh you know getting getting
destroyed here your position is terrible
uh so instead after queen to h4 queen to
d3 was played
uh mamadirov allows this capture we have
queen captures on f2 and now king to
h2 but now bishop to d2 again vasily
goes for the absolute cleanest way of
doing
doing things uh and now what do you do
here
uh really not not much to even attempt
if you try something like e4 that's just
bad that just ends in checkmate bishop
f4 check and that's it
you have to give up the queen or you go
king h1 and then queen to e1
queen f1 queen to f1 will be checkmate
so instead after bishop to d2 we have a5
now trying to create a past pawn here uh
but
vasily just ignores this he plays bishop
captures on e3
as you should and now the problem is if
a6 then we go into the exact same
checkmating pattern that
we've just seen so uh mamidorov has to
try something else he plays queen to d1
guarding the the back rank but uh to no
avail just uh b
captures on a5 now vasily also creates a
pass pawn
b6 and now bishop to f4 with check
king to h1 we have queen to g3 now
threatening checkmate
and the king to g1 now we have h5
not worried about the past pawn because
both the bishop and the queen are
covering the queening square
so b7 and now h4 now we have queen to b1
kind of giving support to this b pawn
but i mean
it's still guarded twice you can never
push this pawn
so bishop to e5 preparing bishop to d4
check and now queen back to d1
momodaro can only wait and see what
happens queen e3 check and now
king to h1 if king to f1 bishop g3 is
checkmate
there's no way uh to defend against
queen to f2 checkmate if you try this
the guard the checkmate this way
then queen to e1 is of course checkmate
so instead after
the queen e3 checking the h1 was played
but now queen back to f4
threatening checkmate and going after
the c4 pawn
and that there's nothing to do king g1
avoids checkmate but runs into queen
captures and c4
and there is no counter play again this
is guarded so uh here we have queen to
e1
going after the bishop uh just queen to
d for chuck
king to h1 and now bishop to g3 putting
more pressure on the uh on
white's position queen to f1 and now c4
now vasily also starts pushing his pass
pawn
so bishop to e8 going after queen
captures an f7
but it's not a problem just f5 we have
queen to b1
now with support of pushing this pawn
but just queen to d6 again both the
queen and the bishop control the
queening square
so bishop to a4 but now uh queen to b4
offering a queen trade and
there's really not much you can do here
the b pawn is also targeted
so queen to d1 guarding the bishop at
least and now
not going after the pawn because you
don't want to allow any counter play to
white so just c3
guarding the d4 square now with the
queen so there are no more uh
interesting checks here
queen to d7 was played it does come with
check but king to h6 with queen to d8
now
uh hoping for some back rank checking
patterns but
bishop to e5 just guarding that square
we have b8 with queening
uh you have to play something but just
uh queen captures uh
you could go for bishop captures as well
it does allow white to go for some
checks
uh but in the end you will still be
saved king g5 queen the eighth check
you're going to do a full circle
king f4 queen captures with check king
e5 queen to e1 check and now for example
king of six
and there are no more useful checks here
so uh
that while that is possible uh vasily
decided to do it without
much uh you know uh thinking so he just
played queen captures now everything is
nicely defended
uh queen captures an h4 check king to g7
and now queen e7 check king to h8 and
now what do you play
queen captures and e6 was played but
there are no better moves
there is no useful check here so queen
captures on e6 was played but now of
course this runs into a very unpleasant
checkmate in two
and i don't have to tell you where it is
because you see that the bishop is
covering this square
so here vasily just dropped his queen to
b1 he played queen to b1
check uh and it was uh in this position
that
uh shakir mamidar resigned in the game
as there was nothing more to be done
here
uh it would be better if it was queen to
e1 check i know you guys love that
one but it's going to be one check so
you know yeah we can't always have it
our way
uh so yeah a really really a wonderful
game so it was a
pretty much a draw uh at that moment
when we discussed here uh maduro could
have just forced a queen trade with
queen tayden but he wanted to grab a
full point he was up upon he thought
everything was safe
but this is just the kind of moment
where you have to be super careful
you you think okay you're up a pawn you
have a better position you have a very
active position
uh what what what's the worst thing that
could happen well the worst thing that
could happen is that you could blunder
everything and lose the game
which is what what happened here uh so
uh careful for that
in your own games uh so uh that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it uh i would
like to thank uh
george georgiou uh daniel borisov kaleem
mcmead
nick watson and henry's programs for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day